[Music]
when I first got my Ultra HD player I
just wanted to buy as many films as
possible to show off the new upgraded
picture quality and HDR I probably
bought about 40 titles so far since
picking up my player earlier this year
and with the majority of them starting
off at 25 pounds it's quite an expensive
hobby when I first began there wasn't
really a reliable list as what was worth
picking up and I soon found out that
just because something was listed as 4k
didn't mean that it was worth getting
over the traditional blu-ray so to help
those out in the position that I was I
decided to put together a list of my top
10 4k films this list is the best of the
bunch in my opinion and all are
definitely worth picking up if you want
to show off your new fancy TV and player
without the way though I'm definition
and let's get into it
Pacific Rim Pacific Rim was originally
shot in 5k and you can definitely see
the difference in quality above your
standard 4k affair the full-screen
picture means that all of the details of
the film are clear and crisp without the
need for zoom on your TV watching the
huge Titans battle one another is
amazing to behold and this massive
upgrade over the blu-ray makes it a must
buy for the format life life is an
incredibly underrated film in my opinion
this horror sci-fi mimics alien in
several ways but it brings a touch of
reality to it with surrounding and
settings the picture here is really
crisp and the high contrast on the UHD
helps to make the Space Shuttle look
sterile and realistic the movie was shot
in 4k and you can see finer details on
faces that make this a must buy for
people who didn't pick up the blu-ray
Methos from the opening shot of
Prometheus I was hooked on just how good
the film looked it had never been one of
my favorites until I watched it in the
improved format which really enriches
the film skin details are incredible
here and everything has a heightened
resolution that really showcases just
how good 4k can be once you've seen the
engineer drinking the black goo over the
waterfall they'll be sold on just how
good 4k can be and you owe it to
yourself to pick this one up
infinity war infinity war was the reason
that I actually decided to buy UHD
player and it really didn't disappoint
the film is a massive upgrade over the
standard blu-ray and features a huge
improvement in contrast picture quality
and colorization thanos just looks
absolutely incredible with finest skin
details like paws of facial hair being
present and overall this is the best way
to watch the movie there's absolutely no
noise or grain and the picture is
debatably one of the sharpest ever put
to film passengers like life passengers
is a massively underrated film in my
opinion the UHD upgrade vastly improves
the film in several ways
presenting it as the sci-fi epic story
that it truly deserves to be known as
the soundscape is incredible and the 6.5
K resolution that the movie was filmed
in really comes to life on the screen
image quality is razor sharp from Grand
spaceship designs right down to the
minuscule pores on fingers and hands
everything leaps up the screen and this
film arguably possesses the best picture
quality out of everything on this list
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 uses HDR to showcase
a wide range of colors that really bring
the fun felt movie to life
the opening sequence with baby Groot
will have you hooked instantly and the
film leaps off the screen shot at
resolutions of up to 8 K the movie is a
market improvement over the initial
blu-ray this was the first film released
for 4k by Marvel and Disney and
definitely stands as a flagship piece
for just how good the format is the
Avengers
The Avengers possesses the best image
quality out of all three films in the
franchise in my opinion the full screen
format brings each character to life and
costume details pause and textures all
above the screen and this phenomenal
transfer even if you already own the
film a massively recommend picking this
version up as it's far superior to the
formal releases the movie is reference
quality throughout and deserves the
higher price tag that comes with in the
revenant the revenant is a thing of
beauty to behold shine 6.5 K and using
natural lighting has allowed the film to
rank as one of the best looking movies
of all time everything is razor sharp
beautifully coloured and the movie feels
like a work of art throughout I really
cannot stress how much you owe it to
yourself to pick this one up in order to
show off your new display it's
outstanding from start to finish and
it's definitely a top contender for
films on this list picture wise Lucy
whilst Lucy may not be the best movie on
this list as far as visuals are
concerned it ranks near the top every
detail is perfect throughout - skin
imperfections textures and hair strands
can be perfectly made out due to the
beautiful image that is presented on the
screen
this is one of the top looking films in
the format and even if you're only soso
on the movie itself you should
definitely consider picking it up but
the reference quality visuals showcase a
is here Blade Runner 2049 movie wise
this is one of the greatest films ever
made in my opinion picture wise is
elevated to a new high that it's almost
unsurpassable by the majority of movies
Blade Runner 2049 is a must buy if you
own
HD television and player everything
looks outstanding from beginning to end
with sound quality really adding a
wealth of experience to the film pure 4k
from start to finish this is not only
one of the best films ever made it's
also one of the best films in the format
so what are your thoughts on my list do
you agree and if not what are your top
films and 4k comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video or
found it helpful then please give it a
thumbs up as it massively helps us out
this is a channel for people who are mad
about movies so that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you